we are going to begin though with more
troubling developments uh on the russia
ukraine border no solution in sight in
that standoff over ukraine amid concerns
about a potential russian invasion
nearly 80 tons of american weapons
arrived in kiev last night to aid the
local military as russian troops
launched new exercises near the
ukrainian border president biden is
warning russian president vladimir putin
that he will be personally sanctioned if
he launches an invasion we have a team
of correspondents covering the story and
we begin with wija zhang at the white
house ouija as the president put it
yesterday an invasion would change the
world good morning
good morning tony good morning to
everybody and now there are growing
concerns that vladimir putin could cut
off oil and gas shipments that run
through ukraine in the coming weeks a
senior administration official says that
the white house is working with
suppliers around the world to prevent an
energy shortage in europe as for that
military escalation u.s troops here at
home remain on standby ready to go in
case the crisis worsens
president biden was blunt about what he
called the enormous consequences of a
russian invasion of ukraine if he were
to move in with all those forces to be
the largest invasion since world war ii
it would change the world
on an impromptu shopping trip tuesday
the president said he may soon be
deploying the 8 500 u.s forces currently
on alert because it takes time to get
them into position
for its part russia has so far shown no
sign it will draw back its roughly 100
thousand troops stationed at the
ukrainian border mr biden said u.s boots
would not go beyond nato's eastern flank
we have no intention of putting american
forces our native forces in ukraine
but we i you know as i said they're
going to be serious economic
consequences if he moves including
sanctions on vladimir putin himself
the senate minority leader offered rare
praise of the president's strategy but
it appears to me the administration is
moving in the right direction while
republican senator lindsey graham urged
the administration not to waste any time
sanctioning putin and other russian
officials
don't wait for the invasion they're
destroying the ukrainian economy they're
throwing europe into chaos
sanctioned him now for the provocation
in a new controversy russia has added
imprisoned opposition leader alexey
navalny one of putin's fiercest critics
and his top allies to a registry of
terrorists and extremists which means
their bank accounts will be frozen per
russian law the state department calls
the designation a new low
gail
new development there thank you very
much weeja